hello ladies and gents this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
at this altitude I can learn flat out
for a half-mile before my hands start
shaking you know I also post some
questions
now it
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton that's the usual
intro music but I'd like you to hear a
brand-new version reimagined by none
other than Justin beretta of The Glitch
Mob you want to revive yourself on the
side of majority it's time to pause
this podcast is brought to you by mizzen
and main don't worry about the spelling
all you need to know is this I have
organized my entire life around avoiding
fancy shirts because you have to iron
them you sweat through them they smell
really easily their pain-in-the-ass
mizzen and maine has given me the only
shirt that i need and what I mean by
that and Kelly Starrett loves these
shirts as well is that you can trick
people they look really fancy so you can
take them out to nice dinners whatever
but they're made from athletic sweat
wicking material so you can throw this
thing into your luggage in a heap or on
your kitchen table like I did recently
and then pull it out throw it on with no
ironing no steaming no nothing walk out
and you could probably wear this thing
for a week straight or make it your only
dress shirt and take it on trips for
weeks at a time never wash it it will
not smell you will not sweat through it
you got to check these things out so go
to 4-hour workweek comm all spelled out
for our work week com forward slash
shirts and if you order one of their
dress shirts in the next week you will
get a Henley shirt for free that's worth
about 60 bucks so put them both in the
cart use the code
Tim TI m and you will get the Henley
shirt for free check it out for our work
week comm forward slash shirts and
you'll see some of my favorite gear
including the one shirt that I've been
traveling with 99designs which is your
one-stop shop for all things graphic
design related go to 99designs comm
forward slash Tim to see the projects
that I've put up including the mock-ups
and drafts of the book cover for the
4-hour body as always you can subscribe
to this podcast on iTunes and you can
find all of the links and resources from
this episode as well as every other
episode by going to 4-hour workweek comm
forward slash podcast spell it all out
or you can go to 4-hour work week calm
and just click on podcast feedback if
you have feedback I would love your
thoughts anything at all who you'd like
to see on this show ping me on twitter
at Stifel comm /tf ER Riss or
on Facebook at facebook.com forward
slash Tim Ferriss with two R's and two
S's this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where I deconstruct world-class
performers to find the tools tricks
routines habits that you can use and of
course those experts range from
billionaire investors to chess prodigies
to Arnold Schwarzenegger to everyone in
between and you do find commonalities
and in this particular episode we delve
into a world that I know very little
about and that is the world of music
we have Justin beretta who is a founding
member of The Glitch Mob and if you
haven't heard that name you don't
recognize that name you'll definitely
recognize some of their music and it
could range from their trailers are the
trailers in which they're featured so
you could list since CD 2 edge of
tomorrow Captain America spider-man 2
their commercial work so commercials for
Fiat howdy and so on they also debuted
their last album love death immortality
incredibly well on billboard number one
electronic album number one indie labels
number four overall digital albums and
this is fascinating because from an
entrepreneurial standpoint not only are
they India they're not associated with a
big label they are artists owned and we
delve into all of this how did they go
from unknown to on top of the world
plankton 90,000 people in Quebec with
deadmau5 for instance we dig into the
war stories the creative stories the
process how that has been refined over
time and you get to hear some never
heard before early drafts of some of
their biggest hits and justin walks
through exactly how those were refined
over time to become what millions of
people now love and listen to all the
time it's a fascinating discussion with
an artist even if you feel like you have
no interest in music process you will
find things ranging from his schedule to
his meditative practice that you can use
it's a really fun interview I hope you
enjoy it without further ado here is
Justin beretta
Justin welcome to the show hey how's it
going Tim it's going well I appreciate
you making the time and as a long time
fan I appreciate you making the music
first and foremost
oh yeah it's my pleasure to be here I'm
a huge fan of of all the the for our
Empire as well so it's an honor to get
to talk to you and I know we I guess
initially connected via Twitter I think
it was is how we we came in contact is
that how the how the pieces came
together yeah I think so I think you you
had posted something on sound tracking
which is a app that we both used and I
started following on there and then yeah
we just kind of just started chatting
from there that had to be a year two ago
yeah yeah but it probably was and then
I've continued as a consumer of music
and now we finally have a chance to dig
into the music so the first question I
really wanted to ask you is what you are
world-class at or what your closest
friends or associates or band members
consider you world class at mm-hmm
that's a good question um you know I
think that we're known to perform crazy
intensive perform and produce really
crazy intense cinematic music we're kind
of often are in our own category and
we're also known for being a very DIY
operation we do almost everything
ourselves we have we and we own our own
label and we have a very close
relationship with our fans so the how
does the closeness with the fans
manifest itself and and what has led to
that well you know the funny thing about
let me know because your fans are are
diehard I mean really really diehard
which I appreciate absolutely so how did
how did that happen what do you think of
the factors it's you know I think um you
know one of the one of the interesting
things about about building something
that's very DIY is it's been a very very
slow burn for us it's been we've been at
this for a while you know I think the
very first Glitch Mob show just the
other day by the way I should mention
coach Bob is myself two other guys edit
and who names ed and Josh who
we're also in the group and um we're
gonna start we Josh found the very first
mixtape from us
in I think was 2006 the other day when
he was cleaning out his house so it's
been a it's been a long process for us
and right out of the gates
we were we were interacting with our
fans I mean this is gonna date me but
this was back in the days of MySpace so
on her mixtape it said myspace.com / The
Glitch Mob but but right away what we
would do is we when we first started
playing shows we would finish every show
and we went to take a stack of CDs and
hand them out to people and we continued
that tradition and in fact we still kind
of do that so it was baked into our DNA
from from day one to have a very hand
hand face-to-face interaction with
people and and we've kind of continued
that ethos through into the the era of
Twitter and snapchat Instagram and
everything where we have a very a very
close personal relationship people those
people we know and I mean you know we've
been touring for quite a while now so
and you know we all we actually also
have a group of very ultra die-hard fans
that are in a sort of a forum called the
mob and we meet up with them before
every show and half of the show and we
have you know we do fun projects and
stuff like that so so for us um we also
get a lot of a lot of feedback back from
them on when we were very first started
doing this it it was it was us we were
making these more more dancefloor
eccentric tracks and I think that the
more we started to realize how much for
music has the ability to affect people
and we started to get these stories
about back from people about our music
being a part of their lives in some way
we started to take everything really
very seriously because we have such a
close relationship with people people
they have the the logo tattooed in their
body which is the first time we saw that
we thought wow wow
this is someone who took the time to get
the logo tattooed on their body which we
all have tattoos and our manager does
too so we take we take everything very
seriously and we take the power of music
to be very serious it's something that's
very important to us and I mean one of
the stories of course
that really struck me was the the grant
Corrigan story snowmobile after a
snowmobile accident was I guess
basically diagnosed as potentially never
walking again and fast forward after
listening to the glitch mob and PT and
interacting with you guys planted a
glitch mob flag at the South Pole
after I guess been traveling the
majority of the way in a push sled and
then walking the last weather it was a
hundred feet or 100 yards I don't recall
but just such an incredible story how
did that change you guys and of course
I'm going to come back to the origin
story and ask more questions but how did
that change if it did your creative
process or how you think about your
craft after after that type of story
comes to you yeah I mean I absolutely
did and that was that was something that
really and se got into the DNA of what
we do you know I I think that when we
really realized and when we was so when
we first met grant actually a friend of
his had emailed us and and this is I
think this is also part of us being
really tapped into what people say is
that I mean this this email could have
gone away you know but we we pay
attention to important emails like this
and someone had emailed and said hey
look my friend got a really bad accident
and he's he's never gonna walk again and
you know he loves your music so anything
you could do to cheer him up and so he
said obviously so we had someone on our
team send him a bunch of stuff just like
we signed some you know some drumsticks
and some CDs and everything and then we
just we got a friendship going with him
from there and then he showed up at one
of our shows in Reno and he was on
crutches and he said you know thank you
guys for being there so much and you
know and then he came to actually he
came up to her she'll be played at Red
Rocks and and when he showed us that
video or the picture of him at the South
Pole I mean we all were actually moved
to tears it was it was a fantastic
moment and I think that was something
when we realized that music really does
have the power to to transcend or maybe
it was you know
I also feel like it it's a grant is an
amazing guy as isn't the fact that he
could do that the fact that we even
helped kind of nudge him along and I
think that's also along with his friends
and families and we played a part in
that it really made us take everything
very very seriously I think it's easy to
be cynical these days about everything
you know and and music in particular but
we you know it's it's a very very
serious thing does so it's a very
powerful powerful art form and I was
just having a conversation with a friend
of mine about just the interspecies
differences and similarities related to
beat and music and and just trying to
determine obviously outside of music
theory but what what itch does music
scratch for human beings it's such a
fascinating question for me and it's so
fascinating have you read this book
called this is your brain on music I
have not I I can't remem that enough
it's by this guy named I Daniel Levitin
and he really digs into that whole
question and it gets deep into
neuroscience but um it is a really
fascinating thing and he goes into the
evolutionary thinking behind why why
music does what it does it's almost too
much for me to even get into here fully
understand a lot of the neuroscience but
um it's really interesting awesome no I
I and I wanted to just talk about or ask
you about really what makes the Glitch
Mob unique and different because there
are they're obviously so many bands out
there there's so much noise there's so
many so many people in bands clamoring
for attention but you've you've hit a
point where I was watching this video of
correct me if I'm wrong here but I think
there's 90,000 people in a in Quebec and
what is it that well number one actually
I'm bouncing around a little bit but
what does it feel like to be onstage in
front of 90,000 people is there anything
you can compare it to um you know
actually it's a really hard feeling to
describe and the only way the only way I
think I can liken it to a skydiving have
you tried skydiving before
so you know the feeling with skydiving
where you jump out of the airplane and
it's it's so crazy
you almost aren't even scared it's so
[ __ ] surreal you're like wow okay I'm
just experiencing this right now right
yes okay that's kind of a feeling of
being on on a stage like that is it's so
surreal and it's so there's a like a
terminal velocity with the amount of
people that once it gets so big it just
feels like you're in a dream it's very
surreal and it's also actually very um
there's something really fascinating
that happens in crowds that big where
you can feel even even with that many
people you can feel the way that the
energy of the music can affect people
and as you're you're writing the ups and
down in the waves of the crowd there's
some sort of primal interaction that
happens and with that many people it's
really intense and it's also yeah it's
also a very meditative experience for me
you know I'm a lot of even that show in
particular when I was up there playing I
remember thinking almost getting a
chance to listen to my music and then
see everyone experiencing the music and
and hear it along with them and sort of
getting it does with my own medicine
there so it's a very kind of spiritual
surreal experience to be up there well
has to be some type of communion I mean
it's it's having done some
experimentation in the for lack of a
better term spiritual realm which we can
get into the pharmacology of another
time but the that energetic transmission
that interaction is is from my just
empirical experience at least absolutely
real so I can I cannot even imagine
being the focal point of 90,000 human
beings that's that's it just must be you
know transcendental almost in some level
absolutely what now I you did send me
you sent you sent me an email and we've
we've corresponded of course and you
mentioned a few things and you said that
these are all interesting because not
only are we indie but were artists owned
and I wanted to I wanted you to
elaborate on that because I'm not
familiar with the music industry
I'm an avid listener of music but what
what are those two terms mean and just
to provide some context for people and
I'm reading from from Wikipedia here but
the sophomoric lynch mob album love
death immortality debuted at number one
on the billboard dance electronic Songs
chart now that sounds like a pretty big
deal and I would imagine it is right you
know you know in a way it isn't in a way
it's not I mean I guess you know to be
quite honest we don't pay too much
attention to the charting and everything
I mean it's nice to be recognized for
for what you do and I think I'm you know
it's funny because we're kind of like
the oddballs of the of the electronic
music or EDM world and I which it's just
a kind of a side note I don't totally
use those terms interchangeably I think
and I was actually getting getting a
chance to come on this podcast made me
kind of think about this because just
for me personally when I think of
electronic music it's just music and EDM
is music plus industry plus apps plus
festivals and Spotify everything into
one so I kind of consider them to be two
separate things but I'm that aside you
know the the whole thing with with the
difference between an independent and a
major and in an artist own label so when
we when we first dropped our album and
it did well hit number one on that
electronic chart and I made it to number
13 in the top 20 which is pretty crazy
actually because when you look at a lot
of those the albums that were the top 20
in that point time it was people like
Katy Perry or Eric Church who's this
country guy and a lot of these people
are on major labels so those are the
equivalent of big massive companies you
know these labels are they're huge you
know something like Interscope is a very
big company so then you have an
independent label which is a much
smaller company potentially that is
owned and not back by this effective
huge corporation and then you have an
artist own label which means that we
actually do everything so we provide all
of these things together so it's a very
it in-house operation see so you have
now your operations or not at least the
performances are real productions not so
I would imagine you have had to wear and
you guys have all had to wear a lot of
hats what is what is your team currently
look like yeah absolutely we've had and
I think that's that's also part of our
ethos and and everything that has gotten
us to where we are today is actually
that the wearing of multiple hats and we
all have our own specific things that
that were good at you know there was a
point in time when when we very first
get got this thing going where we
actually built our own light show you
know we have we Josh and I went to Home
Depot and we were hammering and sawing
lights outside of Ed's house while he
was inside mixing down some audio and
when we were very very DIY we we
schlepped this thing in a UL trailer
around the country and I know it's the
fact today that we actually have a team
of people around us that that can help
and actually people that are better than
us at what we do is that was a that was
a big moment for us you know because we
actually would you know we mix and
master our own music actually well the
last albums we've had other people do
the mastering but you know we we produce
we record we do all the music stuff
ourselves we had actually built the
stage show herself we program that we
program the lights we bought the lights
so we kind of did everything and so fast
forward to now we have a team of people
that that are really experts at what
they do so for instance for the live
show there's a guy named Martin Phillips
and Martin Phillips is a specific stage
show designer like that's just that's
what he does so he he meets with an
artist and he's kind of like a creative
director type type guy where he can hear
the music and then we collaborate with
him with with a bunch of other people to
basically create the this the light
delet on the stage show which was called
the blade and there's a guy a guy named
Matt who
Matt Davis who's the programmer so he's
an expert level stage design program
running this guy is he's one of our
dearest friends he's just he's the best
and he he basically programs all of the
under the hood stuff that makes the
blade tick and so when we go out and
tour there's about 14 to 15 people total
to make the show happen got it and how
many of those people are full-time with
you guys or are the is is the core three
are the core three of you the only
full-time mm-hm so the only full-time
people saw the other so there's us
obviously we have a manager Kevin wolf
who has been with us since when since
day one and our booking agent who takes
care of all the live shows named Steve
and he's also been with us and since day
one and then there's a tour manager who
manages everything that happens out on
the road and to make everything else
happen so those are those are the main
full-time people and then we have
someone who does all of the the social
media strategy and stuff and we actually
do all the posting and tweeting and
instagramming ourselves but there's
someone who deals with all the nuts and
bolts of the you know the internet side
of things right got it
and I'd love to hear a little bit this
is going to be very nitty-gritty but I'm
just I know they're gonna be people are
very curious about this when you're in
the studio as it sounds like you are now
what what what is the software that you
use on a daily or weekly basis what are
the tools that you guys use so right now
we base everything on this program
called Ableton and it's a very it's a
very ubiquitous program these days I
think most people are starting to
produce on it and we've actually been
around the block on everything I mean
we've used for the audio nerds out that
I mean we started with Pro Tools and we
moved to Cubase then we've done logic so
we've tried everything and we and on IDI
used to have tons of outboard gear so
the what is outboard gear so that right
now on the term is called in the box
which means everything is done in the
computer like our studio it's just
a monitor keyboard and um and you know
that's an actual piano keyboard for
playing notes and then some studios have
tons of gear that lives on the outside
of the computer so there's compressors
and eq's and a lot of tools that are
these custom boxes that cost thousands
of dollars that are really high-end
stuff that now that the technology is
getting more and more powerful we
actually sold everything outboard and
moved in the box so that we could
actually travel so and it's arguable I
mean there's the whole it's it's the
funny because like the analog digital
argument permeates music in all sorts of
different ways and even in the sort of
you know those people who are vinyl
purists or people who like to listen to
Spotify because it's it's easier say
it's the same thing in the production
side there's some people that think that
analog is the way to get the best
quality sound and we're not really
arguing that but we actually it's a lot
easier because also we have a
distributed studio so our our toolbox is
Ableton a handful of plugins and then
everything is synced on Dropbox so that
way we have we can have sessions open
and all different machines and then we
use these plugins called Universal audio
to actually emulate all the outboard
gear that you could buy very cool and on
the road does that change at all or is
is aside from the the let's say aside
from the actual blade and so on does the
the actual music production side of
things change much when you're
performing or is are you still working
off of primarily laptops with Ableton so
it does change entirely actually um but
the Ableton software stays the same and
that's the benefit of a of the way that
Ableton is put together is that it's
actually a production and a performance
suite all-in-one so we write everything
in Ableton and then because we're all
basically synced up and and everything
is very modular then are so that there's
a system that drives the blade and
that's the thing
his programs and it's called we call Lil
Kim and it's this it's like why do you
why do you call it a little Kim because
we just we just needed a name for it and
it's this big just gnarly pile of
computers and boxes and wires and edges
said let's call a little Kim so it's a
Mac Pro and then it has two Mac minis in
there and the Mac minis actually do all
the MIDI routing for the blade and then
there's another laptop which is a backup
system so if the Mac Pro dies we have a
button if there's a big red button that
will switch because when you're playing
these huge crowds you have to have
layers of redundancy so we have the we
have many many different layers of
redundancy but yeah but Lil Kim it's
still based on Ableton but we move the
entire thing to a more beefy and robust
system and then there's a lot of audio
that comes out and this is actually
something that does separate us from I
would say 99% of other electronic
artists out there is that we split out
our audio like a typical band and what
that means is like let's say you go see
a rock band play because there's a guy
playing bass there's a guy playing drums
and vocals and then there's a someone
who's at the front of house which is the
the sound booth up front who's mixing
all these together to fit the sound of
the room and get the optimal sound now
when you go see most DJ's play they're
playing music that's already been mixed
together so so it's just it's just one
one track and there's not a whole lot
that you can do so we actually are
hybrid of the live rock world and then
the electronic world and that we
actually send out kick snare and all the
different elements of the sound to come
out so that our sound engineer can
really tweak and get the most optimal
sound for each room we plan that's very
cool and the kick kick is the bass drum
exactly yeah got it
and just a just to rewind for a second
what is mastering exactly so so
mastering so let's say we finish our
album I'll give you a real with example
is we finished writing love data
mortality after after two years of
writing it and mastering is the process
of
taking it from being an unfinished
product to basically a finished
listening product that you would buy in
a CD or something there's there's stuff
that happens a lot of it has to do with
evening out levels or changing the the
quality of the sound there's certain
things that have to happen to have it
beyond a recorded on a recorded medium
and it changes depending on what music
it is but it's really just the finishing
process that the last final thing that
makes music all sound consistent or or
for instance um let's say some of it
like one song is quieter than the other
well the mastering engineer was not us
what I would go through and tweak
everything just a little bit so that it
gets to be a consistent listen and in
the bass that in the trouble and
everything is matched throughout it the
the record got it
and I know bouncing around here with
Ableton so Ableton has come up a few
times for me recently and one of the
contexts which I was surprised by is
that not that I have any right to be
surprised cuz I know nothing about this
stuff but Ira Glass of this American
life uses Ableton for his performances
when he does speeches and wants to layer
in audio and so on oh I'll do youth if
you were to create a podcast yourself
would you do would you use Ableton for
that or would that be overkill no I
would I would use Ableton I mean it I
guess it's hard to not be biased because
I use it all day every day but um I
actually think that you can do you can
do some really complex and and
interesting stuff with it or you can do
really really basic stuff I mean
actually Ableton's a program that comes
up a lot because the learning curve is
not too bad I'm for instance a friend of
mine just had a his girlfriend's 12 or
13 year old little brother wanted to
learn to DJ and produce was that's you
would give some a beginner give them
Ableton yeah absolutely so it's easier
than Pro Tools for instance a hundred
percent yeah it's really it's it's not
too hard to to learn in the grand scheme
of thing interesting so I'm at a point
where I'm interested in audio I would
not that I plan on doing it everything
myself but I'd like to
have a fundamental set of audio editing
skills because I find it interesting
yeah
if I'm starting from scratch and I'm
trying to choose from GarageBand
audacity Pro Tools Ableton and I'm
scared I'm starting from Ground Zero so
I have no training in any of them
Ableton would be your recommendation
yeah I would say so also because Ableton
is so robust and it's used so widely you
get the benefit of people like us
hammering on it and and so for instance
there's Ableton has a very reliable
crash feature so if the program crashes
it saves your undo history so that means
that it will pick up so you know you
won't lose a whole lot of it crashes and
other programs have that but because
it's really you know it's a very living
breathing piece of software and it's
used so much by the community I think
that that it's really the right way to
go and the stuff that they're doing with
it over the next couple years I think
it's gonna be really crazy and it's it's
worth the time to to figure it out and
also you can do all sorts of other crazy
stuff with it but even for the really
basic things I mean yeah even for
instance you know um there's progress
it's arguable some people will tell you
that Pro Tools and logic are more robust
and powerful and what they can do and
that might be true however I would say
that Ableton you get the most bang for
your buck I mean we didn't choose it
because it's the absolute best and most
complex Swiss Army knife it's actually
the fastest way to get things done cool
ok no say no more if that's a great
that's uh that's a great way to convince
me sold I I wanted to switch gears a
little bit and talk about the the
commercial success that you've had
because I find it so fascinating and
encouraging that you are artists owned
very DIY yet you have you've your music
shows up all over the place I mean it's
I remember you sent me a number of
lengths some of some of which I had seen
before whether it's Sin City - edge of
tomorrow
Captain America spider-man and just the
list just goes on and on and on and on
and on how how did you as this this
artist owned up start and I should I
suppose asked have you always been
artist own so maybe you can answer that
too but how have you ended up getting
into these massive motion pictures for
instance yeah well and we all we have
always been artists Tony absolutely you
know that I'm just to jump around one a
little bit here I think that you know
the part of our whole genesis was really
just out of the love of music you know
when we first started in 2006 and 2007
we started doing this you would never
say I'm gonna be a producer because I
want to be rich or famous or even cool
you know in fact at that point time
electronic music was was relegated to
raves and I don't it just wasn't even
anywhere into [ __ ] close to
mainstream culture which now it had what
it is so it was funny I mean even
remembered doing interviews at that's
gonna be very first getting some
traction people saying what do you make
what kind of like you know electronic
music cuz was rock and hip-hop was
really the thing so we almost had to
love it because it felt like there was
that's just what we were doing we were
just kind of the oddballs of music and
that's cool because we just like to do
what we do and we are fascinated with
there's a really interesting merger
between technology and artistry which is
which is part of the whole thing it was
sort of like we're we're tech guys and
tech fans and the same time we also like
the art of music so for us it was really
a passion project like none of us ever
decided to so you know what let's make a
band we're gonna call The Glitch Mob but
we're gonna do this it just kind of
happened
so that said that's that's always how
we've done things and when we started
making when we wrote our first
full-length album drink the sea before
that we're making I would say more more
dancefloor tracks it had a more hip-hop
swag kind of it was really like more and
more cut-up hip-hop style stuff where it
was just more dance for music and so we
may drink the sea people expected us to
do that and we took a left turn and we
all were having a you know we were all
difficult
we had a difficult moment in life and
drink the sea for us became it was funny
we all collectively were like having a
sad about something like great breakups
and heartbreak and so we said you know
what [ __ ] what people will expect us to
do we're just gonna make this thing that
was a very cathartic record for us and
it was a very personal record and we
didn't play that for anybody you know we
didn't play it for our manners we didn't
play it for our friends we just
basically disappeared for a year and it
would roll as what when was that what uh
that was that was like 2009 2010 I think
is when I came on ok um and I think was
2010 drink this he came out um so so
that said it we had no particular
intention with that we do about how
we'll be received or anything it was
very like a diary piece for us was a
very introspective director record and
the interesting thing is that the the
commercial success or the the superhero
movies that started to glom on to it
just happened naturally we never
intended for that to happen I think what
we are we didn't even understand why I
said oh wow these this is really cool we
also just happen to like superhero
movies so it was a really cool thing we
and were you a comic book nerd growing
up or no no I wasn't a comic book nerd
but I was definitely into you
transformers and I don't say that in a
derogatory way since I have like I was a
major comic book nerds no I you know I
wasn't I wasn't I never really got it
I had the Ren & Stimpy comic that was
the only one I really had I love
brennidon
I was really into horror movies and and
um and Stephen King I was read a lot of
Stephen King books growing up and stuff
like that but but yeah but um you know
we never I guess we never really just
intended for that to happen we I I
actually didn't understand why these
movies were choosing our music to use
and I and I I think there's something
inherently cinematic about our music and
something else that that I learned later
in time was that it was about the
dramatic changes in tonality that
happened so this which is something that
we did naturally so it one of our songs
we'll start off and with an emotion and
we'll say okay now this
feels URI and ethereal and then boom it
switches to zombie attack mode and then
it becomes really violent and then back
so we kind of go p-- we play with
emotions texturally like that and that
was just more of an explorative phase
for us are there any particular songs or
tracks that that exemplify that that the
people should listen to you know I can
actually play something right here um
that'd be great
let's see so I'm gonna play this is a
track called animus Vox off of off of
our very first album
hey guys so yeah I kind of get the idea
of there something felt very tense and
you didn't really know what's gonna
happen and then it goes and switches
right there right no I mean that's it's
kind of and I mean this in the most
positive way sort of screams movie
preview right I mean that's absolutely
because yeah you need that sort of
tension build-up shock curiosity and
then go see the movie right the yeah
tell me I'd love for you to tell me a
story of the first movie that you
considered a real movie to reach out to
you guys like how did that happen what
was the email what was the phone call
did you guys believe it you know hey
tell me a story of one of those I'll
tell you one that sticks out and that
was actually the the Sin City 2 trailer
and that one was special because I love
Sin City and the funny thing was that we
were talking about making a video for
can't kill us and that's the song that's
in that video so we were we made it we
had a visual yet so they're like hey no
problem we'll make a twenty million
dollar trailer for you exactly and
apparently Robert Rodriguez who I'm a
huge fan of my love machete and I love
the whole of his his whole thing in
grindhouse
and someone he said hey we want we want
to use this song for the trailer I was
like well we don't have to make a music
video and you know it's just it's just
the most badass thing possible and and a
lot of the times they will with the
people who cut movie trailers who are
actually in general the people who make
movie trailers are a separate and I'm
not an expert on this by any means but
this is from what I understand is the
people who make movie trailers are
different from the people who make the
movie especially in these big these big
companies but it's different with Robert
Rodriguez so he actually does everything
himself he's kind of like us so he
actually chose the song he found it and
then he stuck it in there and I think
that song can't kill us it's just it was
for us it was it's just pure distilled
badassery and I and the fact that that
ended up in that movie I was like really
I you actually is that going to happen I
and even doesn't this doesn't hurt
having Jessica Alba in there either
know that moment God knock so did Robert
Rodriguez just email like info at the
glitch booth calm or like I had give me
some details here so there's a company
that and that basically is serves as an
agent for licensing and everything like
that so they're called they're called
zinc and they're from Los Angeles and
they basically have our music and they
have relationships with people out in
the end of the film and TV world who I
actually don't I don't know a whole lot
about that aside from just making the
music and my minimal access to that so
then I think the way it works is that
the people in the licensing worlds have
so like if you know if you're Robert
Rodriguez and you were cutting a trailer
you put a you put a call out maybe your
producer will get basically demos or
differential different companies will
submit ideas for for what this might be
and they'll put in what they'll call it
temp track which is something that is it
has a general feel of what you might
want what on and you know every now and
again that doesn't happen like that
actually you know sometimes there's a B
there'll be a director who I mean I
don't know him you know he might have
heard the album and just said oh that's
it I'd actually don't even really know
but we got the email I I kind of lost my
[ __ ] and did how did how does someone
like Robert Rodriguez find I'm looking
at your website right now
the glitch mom calm how does someone
find zinc for instance do they go to
some music specific IMDB and then search
for your band and find the contact info
for zinc or how does someone for the big
and I asked partially because not too
long ago and I love your timeline by the
way for your band because if you look at
your like 2006-2007 and then you have
2010 for the for the for the first album
it matches my first book in second book
and I remember doing a trailer for the
4-hour body and I just wanted from the
very beginning in my head I had splinter
this track from Sevendust in my head and
I wanted to license it
and with a larger label now suffice to
say I was like cool just reach out to
the band get the okay no problem yeah
and it was the most complicated quagmire
of an experience it's like oh wait no
there's 17 people this isn't true with
splinter but you look at some songs
that's like no there are 17 people who
own it but then there's 17 people who
wrote it and then there are 17 more
people who you need to get permission
sort of I was like oh my god this is
really complicated so it would be really
nice to just reach out to for instance
an agency or figure out it was hard just
for me to figure out who owned what so
how does someone find the zinc agency
and then reach out to them about your
music for instance well the interesting
thing that this kind of actually goes
back to being artist stone is that we're
very small and a nimble organization
because there's not that's part of the
the thing when that's that [ __ ]
experience you had that's exactly what
it was yeah yeah it's it's now in
fairness just because I don't want to I
want to give them full credit the the
Sevendust guys are total sweethearts and
we're awesome it had it was had nothing
to do with them
not wanting it to happen and it did end
up happening and which was very generous
of them but it was just on the on the
label side so not to interrupt but I
wanted to make sure I said that of
course no it's I think that's that's
that's important to say and a lot of the
times bands on on labels don't know what
their managers are doing to represent
them or sometimes it's hard to get a
hold of them and I just think that
actually and there's I know people that
work at labels there's a lot of super
brilliant amazing people who work at
labels but I think institutionally
they're it's just it's it's it's a
difficult way to get things done when
you have to telephone anything through
17 people to get a yes or no it's just
it's just complex but for us yeah I mean
our manager our manager Kevin for
instance I mean the weight a lot of this
stuff comes in um we'll go straight
through through him and you know he's
really the fourth member we call him a
manager but he's just like one of our
best friends and he's really he's like
the the fourth member of the band and so
a lot of the stuff comes in that and I
think because I mean I can't speak for
other people but but yeah I mean we are
so he reads most emails that that come
in and people sent like sometimes people
will tweet us and I actually read all
the the Twitter posts and so do the
other guys and so between all that we
have a we keep our ear to the ground as
far as is is what's going on but you can
you can also check out zinc it's like Z
Y and C music cool no I I'm just so
fascinated by the interviews of all this
because la music in general it's just
like one big labyrinthine if that's the
right word it's just this this huge
mystery to me in so many ways this you
know I must say that it is to meet you
and I and I I have to say to take
everything I say with a grain of salt
because I actually don't think that I
know that much about the music industry
i oh because we're so strange I actually
don't I say I think that I'm really The
Glitch Mob is kind of the edge case here
so so that's what this podcast is all
about those study on the edge cases no I
am so that's that's part of the reason I
really wanted to to chat with you guys
and so just to to to rewind to Sin City
to for a second was that the lead Domino
that triggered the other movies or well
let me ask you maybe a slightly
different questions so and I apologize
I'm blanking your managers name the
fourth member Kevin Kevin what is
Kevin's superpower what is he what is he
what is he world-class at Kevin we it's
funny we joke about him but we call him
the Buddha and he is someone that in a
world that is it's in getting its I
think it's a complex it can be a very
stressful very last minute high demand
world Kevin as so what he does and what
and I gotta say that a huge portion of
of Glitch Mob success comes back to
Kevin and obviously it's it's a team
effort because the music is really first
and foremost but something that he's
always pushed us to do is just to do us
and there's been times where he's never
asked to hear any of hear music or he's
never pushed us in a certain direction
because he just wants to foster
what's been our natural voice this whole
time and some managers say would say ok
maybe this thing is cool right now you
should do that maybe that thing is
collation dude that he's always allowed
us to just and and and really help us
just do us and I think that part of that
whole process is that he helps us helps
navigate and insulate us from a lot of
the [ __ ] that can happen because
ultimately the creative process for us
can be long it can be fragile it can be
difficult and he basically is there to
let us do what we need to do to focus on
music and just write good songs because
like you said the music industry is a
really complex crazy place but when you
really boil it down aside from you know
all the in the industry side of things
I'm just here to make music and we are
here for that primal connection we were
talking about that music provides
between between people so he helps to to
create that dynamic very cool and well
maybe you could tell me about an
internal debate you don't have to name
names but I'm really curious to know
you've you've had this success which I
hope will continue on an upward
trajectory that creative process in the
beginning you it's just you and a couple
of guys in a room making music right
it's it's all the things in your head
that you're that you're bouncing back
and forth at a point there's a lot of
inbound there's a lot of feedback from
fans there's a lot of feedback from host
a host just multitudes of people how do
you how do you guys resolve that the
external pressures with the the sort of
silence and void necessary to do good
creative work
I think that um well it's it's
definitely having being is so plug and
as a double-edged sword because I think
that if you are plugged in to a certain
extent you're going to internalize some
of the stuff that that comes your way
matter what I think ultimately for us
the I think three of us helps for one
thing the fact that they're there we
have three of us to check each other and
it's a very ping-pong style creative
process that by the time it bounces off
all three of us it the the average of
our own creative worlds is just kind of
is Glitch Mob you know I and I think we
have a very small trusted committee of
people and and to be quite honest I
don't actually think we take anyone
elses feedback from the very small
committee of people we really just
listen to ourselves and even if someone
who we really trust is saying you know I
don't like this or I don't like that
then we still just have to follow what
has gotten us to this point and that is
our own our own intuition and our own
creative sensibility and telling really
telling our own story but what that
might be in the particular moment you
know and and whatever that might be
we have ended up being the type of
artist that can kind of go many
different directions you know I think
some artists make similar albums and say
the same thing but not not the same
thing but I guess you know texturally
speaking actually some of my favorite
artists for instance I don't know if
you've heard this group called Boards of
Canada
I have no there-there were DOA RDS yeah
it's very droney beautiful music and
their albums for me are it's almost like
a familiar old friend that I can revisit
over and over again and they have this
this sort of one world they put you in
and we've ended up being in that that's
just kind of their their DNA and for us
we like to keep it exciting for
ourselves and change things up and
that's just really that's really part of
our process and following that intuition
I think has has kept everything
true and really not not listening to
what people say or what might be cool
and that's kind of also how we end up
being you being the you know the
quote-unquote oddballs of the current
electronic music industries we don't
really pay a lot attention to what our
peers and contemporaries are doing yeah
you know it's it's when you're chasing
what's cool it's already too late you
know what I mean exactly it's you're
you're you're gonna be you're gonna
paddle like hell and you're gonna be 20
feet behind the wave exactly but I'm
curious to talk a little bit more about
this committee because I don't ask I ask
for input but I'm very selective about
the type of input that I let through
yeah into the process and I'm curious to
hear how you solicit feedback what you
ask for
because for example in my writing before
I ask anyone to tell me what they like
or don't like
I ask them to read through a draft and
just indicate what is unclear or what is
confusing yeah
and that D personalizes it makes it and
you get more of a consensus also if I
have five people read it and they all
flag a couple of areas is unclear it
means those need to change yeah that
that I won't debate that that's just a
that's a poor job on my part what what
type of feedback or how do you solicit
feedback so this is an interesting
process I think there's something about
music that is about intuition right it's
like it's it's about getting your brain
out of the way and so this is a funny
thing happens where I'll play it let's
say for my mom or for a friend who
doesn't have to be happen to be a
musician and in a lot of times we'll all
value that sort of feedback in
tremendously in this sense because
people will they'll say something like
you know I'm not a producer but the song
to me feels like X Y or Z and and for me
it's a more pure response and I just
want to hear how it makes people feel or
what the very first thought that that
comes to them versus someone who's a
producer friend of ours who might be
there too who's going to zoom in on the
d2
right so I'm really looking for just
that general feeling or what what is the
song he listened and you what sort of
images does this does this bring up and
I wouldn't say we're really prone to
changing stuff too much although with
the last record we had recorded all
these vocals and we actually wrote all
of the lyrics and all the melodies so
there's a point where we thought this
record was just about done and we had
said you know what we're gonna do this
because we want to try our hand at it
and there was just something not right
about it there's it's hard to put your
finger on when you listen to a song it's
just it's it's such an interesting
mixture between technical and intuitive
but when we play these songs there was
just something that wasn't quite right
and I think at that point that's when we
go play to someone else to almost
confirm or deny what it is I feel I
think yeah that's like you know it
wouldn't I wouldn't say does this sound
bad to you I would just play it for
someone like yeah no no it's kind of
sucks okay no we actually had a entirely
different record done we had vocals that
we wrote and recorded and we deleted
everything and that's why some of these
songs ended up having to 300 revisions
so we had the a tour booked in September
of 2013 and we had all this stuff
pending on that and then we canceled all
of that because we said you know what
the album's not good enough and then
what we ended up doing and all the songs
you hear now we're done in an entirely
different process which was that we gave
the song to a professional vocalist and
lyricist who's that's what they do and
we just let them let them run with it
and and and be themselves and we
realized that at least at this point in
time that writing lyrics and melodies is
not our Forte so although all the album
the lyrics you you're now we're done in
this way got it and what if when you're
in the studio and you don't have a semi
finished product right you're you're
starting from scratch what is the day in
the studio look like when you are trying
to work on a track that is nothing so
the way we're working and and you know
our process changes so
my child to speak to what's happening
right now we're actually in the studio
at the moment I'll be heading over there
after we hop off this call but um what
we've done is we take some time in our
in our solo studios and we write what we
call sketches so we have a very basic
palette of instruments it's just like
it's almost as if you were painting and
you just had three colors or even just a
pencil like what can you do with this so
it's focusing on the structure the
feeling the the overall picture of the
song so ed and Josh and I all went to
our own studios and wrote about five
sketches each over the course of the
week and by sketches you mean you were
all independently DJ's before the band
was formed is that right correct yeah
and we have all producers DJ's on our
own got it so you're creating that and
again I'm not from the music world but
in the same way that say a The Neptunes
might create a beat that someone would
listen to to lay their music on top of
you guys are all creating those that
type of framework of sounds and that's
the sketch got it yeah yeah absolutely
yeah it's something so like you know and
we would all be in our own individual
studios and create creative sketch
that's just a really basic and the
reason it's a sketch is that it's just
um when you have instruments that don't
sound glossy and super complete it's
just like a basic piano patch very very
basic drums you can really focusing on
look at this songwriting itself and so
it's it's just it almost sounds like a
demo from GarageBand or something like
it's really crappy if you heard our
sketches you'd think wow really like
that's that's the song started as oh man
wait that might we might have to get
that as a podcast bonus yeah a sketch
versus finished product would be amazing
actually I have some of those loaded up
oh do you oh my god I would love Cucuy
listen to a sketch and then the finished
product for something yeah I was you
know what let's do it actually and but
while we're here we should we should
jump in really quick yeah I you know
this is funny so no one else's has ever
heard these before outside of the coma
so I thought this would this would be
actually a perfect opportunity to to
illustrate the difference between both
of them so this is a song on our new
record called
our demons and this is this is about two
years of and about three hundred
revisions in between these two so here's
the first one
that we wrote out and we moved to Joshua
Tree in the desert I mean we lived there
for a month to write music and this is
the very first one version six
okay so that's us a sketch and then
here's the completed version version 394
that's version 394 yes
god it's like my blog posts no I love
that though because I've interviewed so
many people on the podcast and if you
look at the top performers the and
correct me if this isn't the case but
there's there's a very significant
degree of just obsessive perfectionist
oh yeah required to get to the point
where you create something that has any
degree of sort of pop and longevity
absolutely and there's there's really I
mean and it doesn't that doesn't
necessarily have to have to be that way
for us I think that but the the
attention too I mean the attention to
detail is really it's just microscopic
and I think that that really it goes
back to caring about and the funny thing
is that it's not for anyone else either
it's like you just have to know that
every every punctuation point is there
and that you know if everything is just
right what did do the and that and I
don't know if I should call them sound
songs or tracks my vocabulary for music
is off what do you prefer to call songs
I actually I kind of use them
interchangeably okay so what do you or
most the songs that have had the the the
widest appeal that have ended up most
popular what do they have in common if
anything whether that's the actual in
the the end product or in the process
that goes into it or otherwise there's
those two there's two kind of points to
that that are really interesting so I
would say one of our most popular songs
and I've thought about this a lot and
and one of our most popular songs is
fortune days and the interesting thing
that happens with this is a funny side
now because I actually have that the
sketch loaded up right here if we want
to oh yeah yeah yeah I'll play right for
you right after this but um so when we
work on songs we have working title so
when we make a sketch we just write
something to some whatever there's like
kind of an honour moment on our mind at
the time there's a really funny working
titles for all these
so fortune days it used to be called
something's about to happen because it
feels like if there's something it's
just tense I don't know something's
about to happen to their songs like that
are it's another one called yacht sex or
super bang attract so it's like kind of
just ridiculous funny stuff so fortune
days something's about to happen when we
wrote that song which ended up being one
of our biggest tracks and and it's the
same with our other ones are the ones
that we didn't expect to be the biggest
tracks this was not the leadoff single
or anything it just took on a life of
its own and so and it's the same thing
happen with love death and mortality the
ones that we thought were gonna be okay
this is definitely gonna be the one that
takes hold absolutely was not in fact in
fact can't kill us which we wrote the
whole the which ended up being the one
on Sin City and the one that was if you
look on Spotify it's our most played
track from from that record and it's the
video on YouTube and everything
obviously can't kill us yeah that one
obviously resonated with many people but
that again that was the one that we
didn't think was was gonna be that was
the like let's just write one just
really kind of weird off the cuff badass
song but for us that was us just letting
go a little bit and running with
something that that we didn't really
care if it had any any sort of resonance
with with people I love it so fortuned
is one of the most popular tracks from
The Glitch Mob you have the draft
yes sketch I'd love to hear the sketch
in the end the finished product or us or
the later draft totally yeah I know what
else has ever heard this that's just you
and I here Tim this with just us it's
just the two of us
okay so that vibe so then I'll play just
a little clip of the finish which
version was that that was doesn't have
the song number in there but that's July
2009 okay got it
so that was probably about we finished
the album in winter so that was about
six months
very cool so yeah I think that the only
consistent thing that shows the songs
that resonate with people are the ones
that we're never gonna be able to tell
so we just have just given up trying to
figure that out and just kind of make
more music here it's kind of like the
Costanza principle he's like Jerry I
figured it out I just need to do the
opposite of everything that I think I
should do and it'll be perfect it's like
right you just have to take all the
tracks that you you do for yourself that
you care the least about or that you do
for the hell of it end up being the ones
that pop it's funny how how consistent
that is even with my writing also you
know I'll put and I have an attention to
detail in both cases but I'll put so
much effort into something I'm sure from
the very outset it's gonna be a huge hit
and it'll just fall completely flat and
then I'll just kind of vomit something
out that that has a lot of emotion in it
and that rawness I I suppose just clicks
and it's it's it's depressing or really
are you know encouraging depending on
how you look at it because you know I'll
do these things very quickly that pop
and do very well like this recent blog
post on what my morning journal looks
like and I think it's just called what
my morning journal looks like which took
me a half hour or maybe an hour to get
out and then there other posts I spent
30 hours on and and I it's crickets just
crickets Wow you know I would like to
ask you so is is the morning sure I was
gonna ask you what is a post that you've
done that you didn't think was going to
do well and then resonated with a lot of
people is that is that the morning
journal one that that is one example
there's another that I put up which was
that's yeah it's called something along
the lines of do you need to borrow some
strength or borrow some strength today
watch this and it was just I was a
YouTube and bit embed with a bit of
context and it was about I believe that
in particular cases Kyle Maynard who's
this he was born a quad amputee but
ended up being a very successful
competitive wrestler did the military
was the first person to do the military
crawl all the way up Mount Kilimanjaro
it's just an
I've had the privilege of meeting him
spending time with him very short very
very emotionally open and you know makes
me wonder if that's the case with the
music as well even though it's conveyed
through sound and not through words yeah
I think so and and you know that
actually just just maybe you know that
what you just said right there reminded
me of something so one of the people on
our team our art director Dean who helps
curate all the visual aspect is we could
do a home of their episodes on
everything visual from the show visuals
to the album cover
Dean's a super old friend of mine and he
designs everything for us and everything
you see visually passes through him and
the other day he sent me a a text and he
said I you have to go listen to this
podcast there's a radio lab show called
in the dust of this planet and and the
episode if you haven't heard it I
implore you to go listen to it it's just
fascinating and then the whole thing
circulates around the this this
philosopher and the nihilism won't go
too far into it but it's a it's about
kind of the apocalyptic feeling of
what's happening right out in the world
and how the the what I took from it how
it resonates with lynch mob and what he
the reason why he sent it to me was that
there's something about badassery and
stuff and something that initially they
even say that in in the podcast about
why does what is it about something that
is badass that is resonating with people
right now and and it ultimately has to
do with music being like a force field
or a shield and when you said can i
browse some strength it just really made
me think of actually music and part of
the reason why our music resonates with
people is it's almost like and the the
darkness of say our album cover has this
the samurai figure but there's something
about it that says that I've seen into
the darkness
I've seen it and I'm not afraid and what
they say in that podcast really
resonated with me and I almost see music
in the same way of some of this stuff
that that you do of your gear
you're handing people these little tools
although maybe music is a different sort
of emotional or spiritual tool means a
lot of people will work out to our music
and if it helps you get out a couple
more reps and you're set and I think
that you know that that's really one of
the benefits that it has to offer
definitely oh yeah no I need to I need
to pick up this is your brain on music
as well there's another one called
musicology I think it is room usek of
philia one of the two that's Oliver
Sacks
exactly which I really want to dig into
and back in the day I used to take a 5
piece drum lesons and got into hand
drumming recently which cool yeah with
the djembe and a couple of other types
which which I'm really enjoying and it's
just a very therapeutic yeah it actually
do you find so for you do you have a do
you play any traditional instruments or
have you have you practiced any
traditional instruments so the short
answer is no and I think that's kind of
a funny thing and you actually when you
had tweeted this morning and I posted on
her Facebook asking some people what
they would want to talk about and
something that come up one of the guys
posted something like how important is
it for you to learn traditional
instruments to play to perform or
produce music yeah and none of us have
any traditional music instrument
training even if we had we didn't go to
music school or anything like that I
actually can't really I mean I can kind
of get around on a piano I I did go to
UC Santa Cruz and I studied if you could
call it that in the electronic music
program this is more about smoking pot
and playing with crazy sense to be quite
honest but that that aside I Edie Edie
and Josh both played can they can play
guitar and and keys just a little bit
but none of us are really that good at
playing play playing instruments um I do
I feel like I at this point I have an
intuitive understanding for for music
but I've come at it from a very
non-traditional angle actually came in
more via technology I'm when I very
first started messing around
music it was it was through computers
and we do stuff to make up for the fact
that we're not we're not really that
good I mean I'm just like we can we can
get by and Ed's a pretty good piano
player but nothing compared to like a
concert pianist or someone who's
classically classically trained but for
instance one of the tricks we use which
actually we were using this yesterday I
thought this is a very Tim Farriss Ian
trick it is is so for instance in
Ableton there's a plugin that allows you
to to transpose a scale so what that
means is is that it allows allows us to
only know one scale so in the piano
let's say you study C major that's just
one combination of keys that all sound
good together right and then you use the
plug-in to move that around so I
actually only know one scale there's so
many different things - no but I play
that one and then Ableton will actually
translate it for me so what is the name
of that plugin do you know it's just
it's just the Ableton pitch plugin got
it so just there's there's a plugins
that come with an Ableton that allow you
to to program chords and transpose your
you're playing around so that you don't
it's it's basically just just some
shortcuts so then I went on a tangent
there but oh no I love I love two
engines that's the whole point
yeah well I think that so so yeah so we
are actually an example of people that
have had you know we've we've made a a
career but not actually fundamentally
being able to perform music that well
with traditional instruments so how have
you found that to help you hmm
well compared to if there are people you
know an EDM who have traditional
backgrounds you know how is that lack of
formal schooling helped or hindered you
do you feel yeah I think there's a
couple of things there so um you know so
one thing to to mention is that you know
II D before we were doing Glitch Mob II
D wrote music for commercials and I
think it says that this is an
interesting piece of the whole puzzle
it's also ed is a
is a increase so that the detail focus
that really hardcore detail-oriented
stuff comes from from IDI on and he used
to write music for commercials and so
what that what that looks like is let's
say that you're writing a commercial and
it's it's a cheerful commercial for
bubble gum and he would have to write
something that sounds like that or say
that there's a dark commercial for a new
car that's really technological so you
so for years and years he was basically
writing jingles so he has the ability so
you can say Edie we need to we need to
have something that sounds this and he
can actually just like piece together
something really quick and I think it
kind of comes back to some kind of the
Gladwell 10,000 hour thought where Edie
has spent so much time just churning out
different emotions just really little
short snippets of different feelings and
emotions that he had that that kind of
training but it's a very real world
thing it was it wasn't like an actual
music school and so so that said I think
you know for me coming into it really
bending the rules from right out the
gates and having that be part of the way
that I see music I think has been
beneficial because I didn't understand
music really just and I just kind of
understood my own little corner of and I
was just doing my little thing and I
remember when it when someone first
explained a chord to me I was already
actually like you know having a decent
amount of commercial success but I
didn't understand a very basic idea of
music that's like what a chord is right
and and you know it's the same thing
like before we went to go play our very
first show with our new life gear at
Coachella and I was up there playing
drums I had never even picked up a drum
stick in my entire life it's which is
sounds like something that that you have
done I psyche which I actually I saw the
episode of your show you did pain yeah
that was uh that was stress inducing
being
stage I've never been in front of an
audience for any type of music actually
I'd never performed music for anyone
whether one or two people let alone a
sold-out auditorium with you know with
an actual band you know that was
stressful I you know but it was euphoric
at the same time it was this very sort
of pleasure pain mix it was interesting
and once once I got into the flow is
fine even though macaw daeun cesare more
forgiving if you're if you're come
you're transmitting the proper emotion
for a few minutes they're very forgiving
as long as you maintain the flow it
seems yeah that's that's true and I
think that's and that's something my
people you know like when people come to
see us you don't come to see us play
because it's exactly like what you're
saying is not wow they're really really
good at their instrument like if you go
see Santana play you're thinking wow he
is incredibly good at playing that
guitar that is unbelievable you don't
see us but at the same time you still
use you get the feeling of us being up
there being emotive and and and playing
the songs and I think just to jump back
as far as what has helped or hindered
you know I know a lot of people that
have gone to music school and gone to
electronic music school or electronic
production school and I think there's
there's it it can help you and hurt you
because in one way you learn how to make
a song sound finished and proper but you
also learn the rules and I feel like
most of the really good music that you
like is music that inherently kind of
breaks the rules and that's just what's
exciting about music is something that
then inspires you or something that
colors outside of the lines and I think
that had I gone to a music school and
learned the correct way to do it that
they that's the fast track to being an
engineer and being someone who works in
the studio and helps other people
produce albums and that's that's
actually a really cool thing and that's
something that I would love to learn how
to do and figure out is to be a record
producer like a Rick Rubin style I mean
I just Rick Rubin is one of my biggest
inspirations seeing at what he does but
that's a very different thing than
someone like
us who are you know we're just kind of
off in our own little corner creating
our own little soundscapes
ya know it's a it's funny you mentioned
Rick I'm hoping to have him on the
podcast so I might tap you for questions
oh yeah the so if you were to and I have
just uh just one or two kind of longer
form questions than I'd love to hit you
with some rapid-fire questions from some
of the listeners
if you were sort of assigned sons it's a
very dreary word if if you volunteered
for teaching me how to produce music or
make music using the tools that you have
because I've always found music very
intimidating but let's just say I were
to spend a month with you and you you're
you you had you know you the the prize
was several million dollars to get me to
the point where I could create a
finished track of some type that didn't
make people cringe
where would you where would you have me
start what does that first week look
like that's a great question so I think
that the the core of a really good song
it really honestly has to do with with
what you want to say so I would actually
do some like let's say I would I would
ask you to go find 10 tracks that are
that resonate with you or something that
so maybe I would want to produce a track
that sounds like this or this is really
what I'm feeling right now I just to get
get you in the the general creative
space of thinking about what you're
really trying to say and then the next
step would be creating let's say a
sketch kind of like like we do um and
and focusing on some very basic building
blocks of music so you know the very
basic electronic song will be a
combination of drums melody chords and
bass so those are the building blocks of
a song and you can an electronic music
is so fluid you can kind of move all of
those those things around so we would
have we would go over
um what all of those different things
are and how they play together and it
and actually I wouldn't spend too much
time on learning music theory you know
and as this is kind of goes back to what
I was talking about before is there's
ways to shortcut all that stuff to where
we could just learn one scale or maybe
not even just learn ok these notes sound
good together and there's a there's a
thing in Ableton that you could lock the
keyboard to a scale which means that
like if a cat walks on it it'll still
sound good and have an entire band of
six cats on keyboards that's actually a
great idea the cat Bob oh man so we get
on the trademark lawyers that that
actually sounds like it could so so yes
so we would I would put some tools in
place to to get everything fixed so no
matter what we did it was gonna sound
good and then and they just kind of I
think the the next step is you know the
interesting thing something that's that
that's changed over the past couple
years since we started is that you could
actually buy sound sets that are really
good mmm
and this wasn't this didn't exist when
we very first started and makes me sound
like a sorry we used to have to write
liner lock up the soundscape uphill both
ways yeah I mean I mean compared to what
we actually had I mean if you took two
people who have actually been doing it
very long it's probably I probably sound
like a snotty child's compañías started
in 2006 there's people who who actually
had to bright music on punch cards and
stuff like that just actually pretty
crazy but that said you can like we
could walk into Guitar Center now me I
don't know this is a good answer I'll be
like Tim let's go to Guitar Center we're
gonna spend $100 and like buy a great
sample kit because the stuff that people
have now art because it you know
out-of-the-box stuff sounds so good so
we would find some really good samples
that resonate with you that you like
because a lot of music production has to
do with starting with really good source
material and then
and taking away stuff is actually a lot
more important than adding to it so what
I mean is like if we went to Guitar
Center and bought a sample study that
was good it had a really good source
material and then you put a bunch of
stuff together it's a lot easier to to
start shaving away and removing this
stuff that's not there to get everything
fitting in its right place when you have
a finished track let's just say like the
the finished fortune days and I and I
and again this is speaking from pretty
deep in my ignorance of pool but if I
look and say garage band and you have
multiple tracks right four different
vocals or music tracks or whatever how
many separate melodies drums etc do you
have in a finished song like fortune
days it really changes on a song to song
basis what would you say I read that the
average ranges the averages is somewhere
around you know 50 Wow and it could it
can be much I mean some songs we've had
over a hundred tracks and some songs
have been have been less also because
it's the tracks that we write are
especially something like fortune days
there's there's so many different parts
to it and the way the way that it's
talked about in music terminology is so
it's like each section you assign a
letter to it so like the intro is a and
then the first the first thing that
happens right after that when the drum
is robbed would be called B and then it
goes back to a so it could be like you
know an a pop song can be a be a C style
layout it's me like that right now you
know our songs are like a b c a d c b
then it goes on but kind of goods we
have a lot of like complex pieces moving
around so because it's like that we
don't always recycle the sections over
and over again then it can be you know
in each one of those sections can have
you know 10 20 tracks and and there's
really a lot of layering that goes onto
and i say that's that's something that
if there are any producers out there
listening that are looking for
production stuff that's it that's a big
that's something that we spent a lot of
time on is the layering of the sounds
and the sampling and all the songs you
hear have been processed and in our
complex packs of many different pieces
together to make one sound so that it
sounds custom and not like anything that
comes right out of of the box
what uh what percentage of your samples
we are sort of off the rack versus
custom you know it changes on an album
to album basis but um say a lot of the
stuff is is custom we're we're pretty
like so if let's say you open a
synthesizer a very popular synthesizer
that's used right now it's called
massive so you can open it and there's a
set of presets in there and you can
cycle through them or you can you can
clear out the synth and then design from
the ground up and we do a lot of that we
do we do both but a lot of our sounds
are are customized and what that allows
us to do is really really control the
sound and if we do use stuff that is out
of the box or preset we mash it and
process it and layer it to the factory
really couldn't tell right who besides
The Glitch Mob what other bands might
you recommend people listen to if they
want to hear good layering that's a
that's a really good question
um I'm listening to right now so there's
a because a producer who's a good friend
of ours called a Mont Obon and his music
is so complex and layered in his album
fully room like he out layered everybody
what was the name of the album again
yeah I was called fully room for the fol
u I like the sound effects yeah
absolutely and he went out into the
world and recorded sounds of me just
there's actually a little mini
documentary about it it's really
fascinating but he's recording sounds of
animals and motorcycles and walking
around on weird sticks and rocks and he
made a whole album that's almost
entirely comprised of stuff like that
and and so when you really if you put
that on your headphones and listen to
that that is a real master level mix
engineer creative undertaking very cool
I would love to ask you some some quick
questions from from some of the
listeners out there and then perhaps we
can listen to another track and then
wrap up for this round one so the first
question is uh I'm gonna he gave me two
and I'm gonna have to take the more
ridiculous this is Jan havoc do you pee
in the shower I assume the answer is yes
I mean every gotta shower of course yeah
I think it's actually at this point
especially in Los Angeles you you're
you're half to the drought police would
come and get you
in the BT winter this is the club this
is the desert island question so if you
could take one book one album and one
luxury I would just say one third item
of any type to a desert island what
would they be
that's a great question um so I think my
album would have to be FX twin selected
ambient works okay book and then that
changes so much so book is going to be
the Unbearable Lightness of being okay
and third luxury item and mic MX yes you
need gotta hope there are some coffee
beans on that island yes Kim X is great
have you tried the Aeropress I have
tried their crest I really like it yeah
yeah the Aeropress is great if you're
gonna make coffee for more than two cups
though the Chemex is is a good way to go
very cool alright next question you know
this is one I think a lot of people are
curious about so if you're comfortable
answering it what are your different
revenue streams for for the band for the
worst yours do so this is an interesting
point actually that I don't think a lot
of people know but we don't make any
money from touring to be quite honest
there's a lot of money
we take all of it and we dump it all
back into the show so that touring for
us I mean hopefully at some point it
gets there but it's really a labor of
love I mean the whole the process of
building the blade and all the bits and
pieces that make the whole thing tick
was really expensive and we just decided
that we want to do this and so dad is
not a writer for us you know eventually
I'm it's kind of like an investment I
mean you know as we keep touring with it
maybe it will make some money down the
line and touring is a very it's a very
expensive undertaking because you know
there's those people that have to set
the set to show up and write that
everything has to travel around and be
afraid it internationally and everything
so there's a there's a lot that goes
into that a lot of people do make money
from touring but right now for us the
equation is not that um so most of our
our I'm the the what keeps the lights on
is actually mostly the licensing for us
and the music and the music sales very
cool do you guys do any merch you
probably we do it yeah yes we have them
we are actually an idea that's that's
another thing is that I'm I'd say a part
of the our whole DIY ethos is that we we
have a lot of merch and we've actually
worked on a design a lot of the stuff
ourselves I'm almost everything you see
English my world is something that has
passed through Assam but yeah you can
see our our merch stores a lot of really
cool stuff when we collaborate we've
collaborated with some friends of ours
and made some some some cool stuff
very very cool are there any bands that
you're aware of that you suspect make
the majority of their money through
merchandising yeah you know that that's
that's actually I was just talking with
someone about this yesterday now that
it's kind of fun you managed mentioned
that but I'm in in the kind of punk rock
landscape as it's evolved into a lot of
those bands the whole Warped Tour and
and I I don't actually know this to be a
fact this is someone who course someone
else who told this to me but a lot of a
lot of what happens if you go to work to
her it's a lot of young younger fans
there and all the bands who play there
don't get paid a whole lot of money but
they make
their money from for merch sales I don't
know sort of the majority but but
there's you know that Holt touring
entity is set up around the fact that
they have these huge merch stores that
there's like a big merch mall in the
middle of the Warped Tour as it travels
around got it
yeah sounds like Ozzfest yeah which I've
been to a couple times that is a blast
at Shoreline Amphitheatre at least and
just insane yeah let's see so this this
is a good one this is from I'm gonna
paraphrase here this from Agatha fox
what are what are some of your fears my
fears oh that's deep yeah yeah that's
that's really that's a good question um
I have a very light question to follow
this one up okay what am I I you know I
I had a crazy long conversation with my
dear friend ben de root is another music
producer just the other day we were
coming back from the gym and we we were
talking about how the climate is [ __ ]
and how it seemingly everything is
turning from what could we do to prevent
total climate catastrophe to now that
it's happening um what how are we going
to wrestle with this catastrophe and the
more I think and and read and learn
about what's happening with the the
current state of Earth's it's it seems
to be pretty doomed maybe not for us in
our lifetime but definitely for our
children and our grandchildren so that
is it's a it's a pretty scary thought it
is it is just as a side note for folks
I just recently interviewed Peter
Diamandis who's the chairman of the
XPrize he does a lot of work with space
technologies and
he's the co-founder of a company called
for instance Planetary Resources the
idea being to send ships to close
orbiting asteroids to mine precious
resources to bring back to earth or I
use extra planet airily and he is very
he would be called by a lot of people a
techno optimist but I I was similarly
just in the last year's so especially
after talking to climate scientists
getting very depressed and kind of put
into a Malaya's about it's like wow like
the whole plant is just gonna be boiling
in 30 years if we keep it up and Peter
was talking about and what's spent too
much time on this but talking about how
they could actually put up a pain in
space that could be rotated very
precisely almost you know to to and to
enlarge or or lessen its profile as it
in between the Earth and the Sun to
modify the amount of energy hitting the
planet's surface and that he basically
said even like I think we're going to be
able to predict I'm sorry prevent sort
of catastrophic meltdown but if we're
not the good news is they're actually
technologies like this so we can
absolutely deploy to minimize some of
the damage that was like huh that's the
first time I've heard anything of that
so Wow just isn't there Simpsons episode
about that isn't mr. burns blocked the
Sun you know I wouldn't doubt it maybe
maybe we'll all look back in 50 years
and be like oh my god the Simpsons
[ __ ] called it that's a bit once
again and this say no exactly like with
the didn't they have a Barack Obama like
versus Mitt Romney prediction like like
you know ten years ago I mean the
Simpsons I think there are people with
with the ESPE working at the Simpsons as
writers but a little bit a little bit
better also just I I am with you to you
know following someone like Elon Musk
that is saying you know what I'm just
gonna go and make this reality better
because I mean I get just everything
that that he does completely boggles my
mind so it makes me feel a little bit
better to know that there are real-life
Tony Stark's out there doing what they
can working on the problem
so to ask a much lighter question it's
sort of a what is your favorite pastry
this is from medium-rare
my favorite pastry I think it would have
to be just a plain croissant and you
said it correctly to I is there any
particular way you guys celebrate after
shows no you know there's a week we have
a pre-show meditation we do I want to
hear this before every single show and
we've been doing it for a couple years
now and before we go on we have a huddle
and we just it's just a quick 30 second
meditation and we say let me say here's
to the now and it's just a way to let
everything go and focus and go onstage
and it really it really helps after the
show I know we don't really celebrate
too much I love the pre-show so is it
here's to the now and then 30 seconds of
silence yeah exactly we countdown we say
it in unison and we also grab all the
whatever other team members are in the
room and then we do do a quick
meditation yeah just like take a deep
breath and then have silence I love it
when you think of the word successful
who's the first person who comes to mind
said that's a great question um you know
I don't know if I could actually pick
one person but I would I would say that
I'm so fortunate to be surrounded by so
many people that I consider to be
successful and I guess it can be boiled
down to the way that I define success is
someone who's really genuinely excited
about what they what they get to do and
and is carving out their own path I need
anyone from someone like my sister who's
who's in medical school working to to be
a doctor who I was just talking to who
would think as an as an incredibly it's
an incredibly difficult path um but what
you know what she does I mean I guess if
difficult in the sense of you know I was
just talking to she's working at the the
ICU right now and I think it's a
said it could be a really heavy job and
I think of other people who are all my
artist friends in LA who are getting to
create and do these things but I did the
the fundamental link between all these
different people is just doing something
that really lights lights you up on the
inside definitely let's see if you could
give how old are you at the moment I'm
34 34 if you could Wow we've got pretty
closely matching timelines I love it if
you could give your 20 year old self one
piece of advice what would it be chill
out calm down
[ __ ] in what in what way I feel like
myself and other people I know that you
know and that are in the early to
mid-20s get really wound up about things
having to be a certain way or is it good
I don't know I just I think that I'm
enjoy because it all kind of doesn't
matter as much as you think it does yeah
that's the truth will this be will you
remember this in 10 years probably now
people don't even remember a tweet 12
minutes later that is the truth into the
slipstream is there I I have never been
to an EDM show of any type what show or
festival should I go to that is that's a
great question I think that um if you've
never been to a show I think wait you
should come you should come to see us
play absolutely oh yeah bias especially
because now that has that has to happen
I remember we missed I think we missed
each other by day in San Francisco or
something like that and I was gutted so
yes that must happen next time you
should you should come on if there are
if you know if Daft Punk ever plays
again if you're gonna see one show your
Desert Island show I would say if they
do another tour you have to go see them
play because what they do
and they have really set the bar for
everybody but it's just it's the perfect
they're there live show is the perfect
marriage between just fun
visceral classic dance music and crazy
techno futurism I mean it's really it
really changed my life
wow that's AMA statement I love it okay
yeah that's that that would be it
do you have any particular morning
rituals what does the first hour of your
day look like yeah I do anyway changes
also because the way that Glitch Mob
works is very much in phases our years
rotate from face to face so there's
there's some studio phase which were in
right now then there's tour prep phase
tour - a recovery and then rinse and
repeat so right now I get up so probably
around 8:00 and I I'm editing every day
and I have for how long 20 minutes what
type of meditation I practice
Transcendental Meditation mm-hmm
and I've tried all sorts of different
different types and this is just the one
for me which I know I've heard you say
in the podcast - that just kind of stuck
I've yeah I've done yeah did it this
morning yeah it's great I do it so I
don't actually do it twice a day every
single day and I hope my teachers don't
hear me say that yeah you know I wish
it's since we're since it's just the two
of us talking I the the - I feel like a
failure if I mentally commit to two and
then can't do two or I don't do two but
once in the morning has a tremendous
effect for me yeah it's really it's
really changed my life it's been a
couple years for me now and a friend of
mine sort of gifted me a course because
he works for um the David Lynch
foundation and so I got to to take the
class and it's it's really just been
life-changing it's in it's because I've
been able to stick with it and actually
keep it because I'm just reading I've
read so many books about mindfulness and
meditation and I've taken different
courses and it's just it whatever we do
at TM just happens to be something that
you can do on a day to day basis and
it's it's really it's really quite
simple
um do you do it in in
do you just wake up and sit up against
the headboard and do it or is that after
you brush your teeth after breakfast
wouldn't what's when do you do it
so I think it you're actually an
important part of my important part of
my morning ritual is that I get up and I
don't look at my phone or my computer
for the first hour and I and I have this
quiet time I think and I you I I used to
be the type of person where I would get
up and right away I'm like emails texts
treated with whatever looking at the the
hamster wheel of my phone and realized
how much that was scattering my brain so
meditation for me actually was something
that got me out of that state so so I
wake up I don't look at any technology I
make tea and make matcha tea usually or
different on SunShot some kind of green
tea and then I meditate and then I'll
have breakfast or do I do a quick
morning workout there's a lie separate
from a different like you know
weightlifting gym exercise just to kind
of get the blood flowing so I'll do do
something quick then I'll have a
breakfast and then I'll intentionally
plug in after I have and I also will
part of this this time it will be
reading so I get even just you mean just
20 20 minutes to read a book in the
morning before I plug in and jump on the
information superhighway what is the
what would the workout potentially look
like let's say the current workout or
the most recent work out what was the
what were the movements this morning I
interested some some kettlebell swings
God and that's that's kind of like a the
quickest bang for my buck thing to do
and I've been working on on mobility
quite a bit more especially with so much
time in the studio actually I've been
really in beginning really into these
the yoga tuna balls through these like
hard these these these balls of
different sizes that you know you can
take and I think for people who spend a
lot of time sitting down I've been using
them a lot even when were in the studio
we're not sitting in the chair each one
of us will have a foam roller or these
yoga Turner balls and we're doing
mobility stuff so that actually because
sometimes we'll have these sessions that
go you know 12 14 hours
and and so I think it's important to to
do the the focus on mobility and then
I'll have another work out later on in
the day which is weight lifting or kind
of like CrossFit style workouts got it
and your breakfast stuff for that
morning workout what does that look like
you know I have I follow up very like
paleo slash for our body style eating I
was a big fan of actually I've
definitely evangelized her book too many
friends of mine along the way so thanks
for that like you I have eggs almost
every single day and I'd actually I love
that I love the um either scrambled eggs
or just fried eggs with vegetables and
coffee yeah that's the breakfast of
champions
well one more question than I'd love to
maybe close out with the track what is
the best piece of advice you have
received the most important the best
piece of advice I ever received it's
something my father told me when I was
very very little when I was I mean
probably five or six that just kind of
stuck with me and that was don't force
it don't force it and what is that is
that everything is it referring to work
what is that referring to that it's
seemingly such a simple thing that's
really just just stuck with me and it's
been kind of one of the it's become
something of a it's just it's an
aphorism that's that's really stuck with
me I think that for the creative process
that's really our guiding light you know
if something if something is not working
if something is not happening I think
it's really important to just let it let
it be yeah and just let things happen
organically yeah yeah that makes a lot
of sense I like that it's very short
easy to remember and if I think about
you know all those posts that I put tons
of time into her chapters that I put
tons of time into the ended up failing
we're just not doing what I wanted them
to do there's almost always a point
where it was just like wow this is a
grind like this is not it's not coming
together but I'm just going to force it
to come together like a Frankenstein
exactly exactly and I think that that
that very rarely has the intended
results whether it's something creative
or just in life in general is trying to
force a square peg into the circle hole
yeah absolutely well I would love to
perhaps listen to another track for a
bit and then if then you can come back
and we'll learn where we can find out
about you and all things The Glitch Mob
but is there something we could listen
to before we do that yeah this let's all
play um can't kill us off of our latest
album love debt immortality wonderful
so the best piece of advice I ever got
was actually it was for my sister and
yes she's a she's a doctor and she was
remember exactly what she said is
something the effect if she was where
she was working or she's caretaking for
some some older people who are nearing
the end of their life and they were just
talking about what things that they
valued had sort of come and closing the
just closing the door in life and
closing the chapter and they're talking
about what really meant a lot to them
and then it was the things like love and
and friendship and these personal
relationships and I think for me there
was just something about the essence of
distilling down to once although all the
[ __ ] aside what really matters in
life and I and I've never forget that
using that as a guiding light to to just
keep in the headlights yeah yeah it's
it's incredible how easy it is to get
caught up in the minutia and nonsense
it's so easy it's particularly with
technology and just the never-ending
stream of information and inputs
absolutely and I think you know there's
something to music and as a statement
like that or anything that I don't know
if there's a word for in some other
language you might know this but the
feeling of when you feel really small
like when you look at the Stars and
you're you're you feel like your
problems don't really matter I think
that feeling like something you're
connected to something bigger than
yourself yeah absolutely well this is
this has been a blast and hopefully
we'll be able to do a part two sometime
soon but where can people working people
thank you find you ask you questions
online we're the best places to learn
more about you and the glitch mom you
can check us out at The Glitch Mob comm
or on Twitter everything at The Glitch
Mob and myself at Beretta Bo our ETA
wonderful well thanks once again man
this has been great and hopefully we'll
get to do a jam session in person maybe
I'll get to to play around with Ableton
and cause some trouble that's let's do
it thanks Sam all right thanks man
this podcast is brought to you by mizzen
and main don't worry about the spelling
all you need to know is this I have
organized my entire life around avoiding
fancy shirts because you have to iron
them you sweat through them they smell
really easily their pain-in-the-ass
mizzen and mane has given me the only
shirt that I need and what I mean by
that and Kelly Starrett loves these
shirts as well is that you can trick
people they look really fancy so you can
take them out to nice dinners whatever
but they're made from athletic sweat
wicking material so you can throw this
thing into your luggage in a heap or on
your kitchen table like I did recently
and then pull it out throw it on with no
ironing no steaming no nothing walk out
and you could probably wear this thing
for a week straight or make it your only
dress shirt and take it on trips for
weeks at a time never wash it it will
not smell you will not sweat through it
you got to check these things out so go
to 4-hour workweek comm all spelled out
four hour workweek comm forward slash
shirts and if you order one of their
dress shirts in the next week you will
get a Henley shirt for free that's worth
about 60 bucks so put them both in the
cart use the code
Tim TI m and you will get the Henley
shirt for free check it out for our work
week com forward slash shirts and you'll
see some of my favorite gear including
the one shirt
that I've been traveling with this
episode of the Tim Ferriss show is
brought to you by 99 designs 99 designs
is the world's largest online
marketplace of graphic designers and I
have used 99 designs for years including
to get cover concepts for the 4-hour
body which went on to become number one
New York Times number one Wall Street
Journal it was a huge hit and here's how
it works and you can check everything
out including some of my competitions
you can see these book covers and so on
at 99designs com forward slash Tim
whether you need a logo a car app a web
design an app a thumbnail a t-shirt
whatever you go to 99 designs com you
describe your project and then within a
week or less you have tons of designers
around the world who compete for your
business and submit different ideas and
designs and drafts you have an original
design that you love or you pay nothing
it is fantastic I have used it I have
mentioned it before including in the
4-hour workweek as a resource check it
out
99designs comm forward slash Tim and if
you use that link you'll be able to see
what I've done on the platform you will
also get $99 as an upgrade for free
which will get you more designs more
submissions so check it out and until
next time thank you for listening